archivos nacionales le envió esta
solicitud al expresidente Barack Obama
el expresidente Donald Trump también a
George W Bush hijo y George Bush padre
no se le envió esta solicitud a Jimmy
Carter expresidente que todavía sigue
vivo porque la solicitud de entregar O
al menos entregar información sobre
dónde están documentos confidenciales
que se hubieran podido llevar de la Casa
Blanca estos ex presidentes pues va
desde 1981 hacia adelante es decir
excluye a Jimmy Carter e incluye a todos
los presidentes que estén desde Ronald
Reagan en adelante esta solicitud de
archivos nacionales también se hace a
los vicepresidentes
Cristóbal el ex vicepresidente Mike
pence fue el último en estar involucrado
en estos hallazgos qué más se sabe al
respecto
claro y es que hay que Resaltar que
desde el año pasado archivos nacionales
le ha venido solicitando el expresidente
Trump que entregue los documentos
confidenciales que se sabía que tenían
en mar al lago cerca de trescientos
documentos confidenciales que pues
muchos dicen compromete la seguridad de
Estados Unidos y el último
vicepresidente expresidente o persona
que estuvo en al al mando alto de la
Casa Blanca en Pues descubrirse que
tiene información confidencial es Mike
pence en la casa de Indiana fueron
hallados estas a dos cajas con
documentos confidenciales de Mike pence
que se habría llevado del observatorio
Nacional de su residencia acá en
Washington precisamente y recordemos que
pues esto viene en medio de los
cuestionamientos y las investigaciones
que se abren también al presidente Joe
biden por haberse descubierto también
que tenía documentos confidenciales no
solamente en su oficina privada acá en
Washington después de haber sido
vicepresidente de Barack Obama sino
también en sus domicilios privados en el
estado de Delaware Que obviamente pues
han puesto en duda esa capacidad moral
de los demócratas de criticar a los
republicanos precisamente por corrupción
y pone entre dicho precisamente esa
carta que se va a jugar el partido
demócrata de cerdos Defensores de Eh
Pues de los derechos y de las leyes acá
en Estados Unidos y criticar a los
republicanos de Cara a esta carrera
presidencial que ya pues se empieza
levemente acá en Estados Unidos para el